un cerdito corre 20 metros hacia la
derecha para comer una jugosa manzana
después camina hacia la izquierda 5
metros para comer una nuez
finalmente camina hacia la izquierda
otros 25 metros para comer otra nuez el
tiempo total que le tomó al cerdito
hacer todo lo anterior fue de 300
segundos cuál es la velocidad promedio y
la rapidez promedio del cerdito durante
este tiempo supón que a la derecha es
positivo y a la izquierda es negativo
redondea la respuesta a dos dígitos
significativos pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo por su cuenta vamos
a resolverlo juntos y para eso vamos a
dibujar un diagrama que nos ayude a
comprender lo que está sucediendo aquí
aquí está nuestro cerdito primero nos
dicen que corre 20 metros hacia la
derecha
así que dibujamos una flecha a la
derecha recordemos que la derecha es
positivo por lo que tenemos 20 metros
positivos ahora el cerdito está acá
luego nos dicen que camina hacia la
izquierda 5 metros así que ahora
dibujamos una flecha a la izquierda que
representa los 5 metros pero como la
dirección a la izquierda es negativa
ponemos menos 5 metros final
nos dicen que el cerdito camina a la
izquierda otros 25 metros así que
dibujamos otra flecha a la izquierda que
representa 25 metros pero nuevamente
como es a la izquierda entonces son
menos 25 metros así que el cerdito
termina aquí para calcular la velocidad
promedio necesitamos recordar que aunque
esto ocurre en una dimensión
estamos trabajando con vectores que
tienen una dirección la dirección la
especificamos con los signos y el signo
positivo indica dirección a la derecha y
el signo negativo es dirección a la
izquierda y a veces cuando trabajamos
con vectores en una dimensión es posible
que esto no tenga una flecha arriba o
que no esté resaltado en negritas la
velocidad promedio es igual al
desplazamiento que también podemos ver
como el cambio en x dividido entre el
tiempo que tardó ese desplazamiento aquí
el desplazamiento es 20 metros positivos
menos 5 metros menos otros 25 metros
todo esto lo dividimos entre el tiempo
que tardó en recorrer lo que son 300
segundos el numerador es igual a 20
menos 5
15 15 25 es igual a menos 10 metros
esto lo dividimos entre 300 segundos la
velocidad promedio es igual a menos un
30 metros por segundo el signo negativo
indica que la dirección es a la
izquierda si queremos especificar esto
como un decimal con dos dígitos
significativos esto va a ser
aproximadamente igual a cero punto cero
33 ahora veamos la rapidez promedio la
rapidez la denotamos con una r minúscula
y va a ser igual a la distancia
recorrida no al desplazamiento recuerden
que la distancia y el desplazamiento no
son iguales y es uno de los puntos clave
en este ejemplo la distancia es dividida
entre el tiempo que tardó en realizar el
recorrido la distancia recorrida es
igual a la suma de los valores absolutos
de estas cantidades 20 metros más 5
metros más 25 metros vean la diferencia
con la operación anterior ahora estamos
sumando y no restando pues en este caso
solo nos interesan las magnitudes de las
cantidades y no su dirección
todo esto dividido entre 300 segundos
aquí tenemos 50 metros entre 300
segundos lo que es igual a 5 entre 30 es
un sexto de metros por segundo
si queremos escribir esto como decimal
es igual a 6 entre 1 ponemos ceros aquí
ponemos el punto decimal aquí arriba 6
cabe en 10 una vez así que ponemos 16
por 16 10 menos 6 es 46 cabe en 40 6
veces 6 por 6 36 40 menos 36 es igual a
4 y aquí vamos a seguir teniendo 6 es
así que el resultado lo redondeamos
aproximadamente igual a 0.17 metros por
segundo con esto encontramos la
velocidad promedio y la rapidez promedio
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo